we have to start with the story so you
published this in 1970 so did you feel
then that it was something that was
going to take off like it did or were
you just doing you you have to be
kidding like I didn't know what I was
doing let alone you had no idea no
that's hilarious I had no idea I just
let it out yeah 50 years later we're
still talking about it that's incredible
so what were your experiences with a
book you're very young so you did you
read this for the movie or had you
already read I actually hadn't read it
before I got the audition for it but as
soon as I read the book I remember going
to my parents and I was like oh my gosh
how did someone write down this
experience this is it yeah how did
someone write this down oh and it says
you're experiencing it yeah and I as
soon as I started the audition process
and started filming I was going through
the exact same stuff that Margaret was
like at the exact same time that I was
shooting the movie so I think it came
for me at the perfect time in my life
because I could draw on a lot of my own
awkward messy weird experiences as I was
exploring Margaret's character as well
yeah puberty is
wrong it was not great for me
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home